hey friends welcome back to deep dive
what you're about to hear is a
conversation between me and my friend
hannah witton hannah is a sex and
relationship educator who's been making
online content for over 10 years she's
pretty famous for having very open and
very taboo busting conversations around
things like sex and disabilities and
love and relationships and stomas and
all that fun stuff and she's got a few
popular series on youtube including
drunk advice the pleasure trove and the
hormone diaries she's also written two
books themed around sex education and
she hosts a weekly podcast called doing
it which i actually featured in a few
months ago in this conversation we talk
about all sorts of things including how
she first got the confidence to start
making sex education content on the
internet at the age of 19. we talk about
the problem with sex and relationships
education in schools and we touch on a
bunch of stuff around how to build
healthy romantic relationships around
sexuality around gender and we answer a
bunch of questions that you guys sent in
via twitter and instagram i really
enjoyed the conversation and whenever i
speak to hannah i'm always just amazed
as to just how open she is in talking
about things that the rest of us would
be would feel very uncomfortable talking
about and i think she does such a great
job in kind of destigmatizing a lot of
the baggage around the idea of sex and
relationships education so that's it
from me i hope you enjoy this episode so
hannah welcome to the show how are you
doing i'm good i'm really excited to be
here with me so you're
five months pregnant now yeah how how do
weeks and months work i think i might be
six months i don't know i'm 26 weeks 26
weeks yeah what what's it been like um a
mixed bag
if i'm honest like the first um couple
of months was the hell on earth
um and now
apparently i'm in the like
good middle bit but i'm coming to the
end of the good middle bit and then it
could potentially get bad again
so i'm like i'm just enjoying this stage
where i'm like i feel human this is fine
nice you see um i i understand you had a
few issues in the first trimester
yeah i was i just was really ill like
fatigue nausea vomiting
all of the fun stuff that you get and um
i basically i couldn't really work for
two months
um i was just like a useless blob on the
sofa just complete like it just
completely floored me and i think at
that stage as well it's like really
difficult because you're not showing
you're not really telling people
and then
yeah it was just like
quite isolating as well because you're
just like i am an ill person and no one
knows
yeah so what did you do in that time
i watched a lot of movies i did in the
end like
reach out and tell people like earlier
than you're supposed to because i was
just like i just i need company like i'm
like i feel physically ill and i'm also
making myself mentally ill by not like
reaching out to my support network and
so yeah like
my parents came down to see me i had a
bunch of friends like taking interns to
like visit which was nice
um
yeah and then
it kind of
gradually gradually got better okay
so like one thing that i've heard people
say is that
you know you feel this like glow and you
feel like the endorphins and it like
feels feels great at some point yeah
i don't know i remember kind of like
coming to the end of the first trimester
and like entering the second trimester
and like
my bad symptoms were gradually leaving
me and i was like when's this glow gonna
show up like come on glow
um
but i don't i don't know i think people
just just maybe say that in comparison
to like how [ __ ] they felt in the first
trimester because
i've noticed like for the last
two months
i'm like this is great i feel like me
again but i don't know if it's like
a pregnancy glow or just like at least i
don't feel like that anymore yeah
yeah the other thing i've heard some
people say is that it feels like your
body doesn't belong to you anymore
yeah the i mean the first trimester i
was calling the fetus a parasite my mom
my mum did not like that one was like
stop calling it a parasite i was like it
is a parasite
and then it got to the point like once
it stopped like literally sucking the
life force from me that i was like okay
you can be a baby or a fetus now like
it's fine nice um but yeah it is weird
you're like something has hijacked my
body yeah
and apparently this is something that i
wanted now it's like because i can feel
the baby moving now and stuff so there
is like
this like oh there's like
this like alien inside of me like i just
keep on thinking about scene from alien
world
the thing like rips out from the inside
of his belly and i'm like yeah yeah
that's what i keep on thinking is like
about to happen at any moment
yeah very strange so like one thing that
always struck me about you um when i
when i first i think i came across your
channel about four years ago three four
years ago
is that you are very very open about
things that people would be a lot of
people would be uncomfortable about
being so about yeah um and you know
you've had this
kind of internet plus writing career as
like a sex and relationships educator
for the last 10 years now or so
um i wonder for people who might not be
familiar with your story how how did how
did we get here
yeah how did we get here so
yeah cast your mind back to 2011 youtube
and it's a very different
kind of landscape and i just was a fan
of a lot of youtubers and was like
watching a whole bunch of different
vloggers and saw that they were all
friends with each other and was like oh
my god how do i become friends with them
well they're all friends with other
people who make videos so i should make
videos so that was definitely one of my
leading motivations was like
infiltrating this friend group they're
trying to make friends i mean success
though
somehow managed it
like they they don't know that i was
just like an absolute creep
um well actually now that they know me
better now they're probably like yes
hannah yeah
fair play confirmed
you're a weirdo um but yeah no i it very
much just started like
there's this really cool online
community and i just want to be a part
of that and
didn't start off making videos about sex
and relationships that came kind of like
within the first year though so it was
quite early days um
yeah i just started making a bunch of
videos for fun
um just connecting with all sorts of
different people like all around the
world
online like making internet friends and
stuff and it was yeah it was just like a
really exciting time
um
to kind of like have this
weird hobby yeah um so what what were
your first videos about
i don't even know like
was it like lifestyle vlogs and that
sort of stuff no honestly i don't even
know it's like the kind of youtube where
you're like
hey it felt like filming a video today
and like this is what's been on my mind
or like or like they'd there would be
videos that i would make that would
literally just be an entire video that
was an inside joke with me and my
internet friends like oh like okay that
was the video yeah um
yeah because it was a very like
non-mainstream thing back in 2011 yeah i
guess sort of 2007 through
2012
sort of feels like oh kind of the golden
early days where people were just doing
stuff and there wasn't such a kind of
monetization machine behind the whole
thing and a lot of the people that i
aspired to and a lot of the people that
i watched online were those like
initial like 2007 2008 like vloggers so
i was very much like watching these
people who had kind of like
you know were the pioneers were the ones
that were like actually creating like
what youtube culture was at that time so
it was very much influenced by that
which was it was very community based
and very much just like let's all have
fun
so you started off making these kind of
random videos talking to your internet
friends yeah
what happened then like how did the sex
and relationship thing come into the
into the mix yeah
it's really tricky like sometimes i
look back and be like how did this
happen and then i think sometimes i may
be assigning too much meaning to like
earlier experiences of like ah that is
why i'm a sex educator now but like
you also have to kind of
i don't know accept that
it was just a bit random as well rather
than like there being any deeper meaning
there um but there was like an american
um youtuber who made a lot of videos
about sex and did like sex education and
i watched a ton of her content
and was just really inspired by it it
was where i probably got most of my sex
education from like i was 19 at this
time um and like previously like
i hadn't really been
scared of talking about sex like
i remember being like 14 in the class
where you're like supposed to put
condoms on
bananas although we were given test
tubes
which is what that school had access to
and like no one in my group wanted to
even touch the condom and me 14 years
old i was like oh god like give it to me
put it on the wrong way around and it
just like starts rolling up and the
nurse is like ah it goes on this way
around but you know this is why you've
got to practice first because
you better get it wrong on a test tube
and not a penis
um
yeah and then like i remember when i was
17 like i went to a catholic college and
um
we had a class on like healthy
relationships because you still have to
do like re and stuff
um and then i was like are you gonna
teach us about like contraception and
all of this stuff and the teacher was
like it's against the catholic church i
can't
tell you about those things and i was
like we're all 17 18 years old here like
we're all having sex like just like had
a bit of a
moment
i'm like
like challenging my re teacher
um so all of that that was kind of like
the backdrop of then like then i found
the information that i was looking for
online and suddenly was just like oh my
god i wasn't taught this
like this is all new information to me
um
and then it was like
i did kind of like see an opportunity
there because there was nobody making
sex ed videos in the uk
and it was something that i was really
interested in
loved talking about and also wasn't
scared to talk about yeah and by that
point as well like i've been making
youtube videos for like just under a
year and
i've grown like a very small audience at
that point but you know the demographics
on youtube um you know it told me that
they were mostly young women and so i
was like i want to
use this i'll be a very small platform
for like good and like have a positive
impact on this community and so then i
was like
i'm going to make sex ed videos how how
small was the audience at the time can
you remember
are we talking like dozens or hundreds
or thousands like
what's probably more in the hundreds to
thousands oh okay well cool so by like
today's time yeah i think like by
today's standards people are like oh you
know
before 100 000 and stuff it almost feels
like like
maybe not quite a thing or something but
like really the
how you feel about the numbers really
changes as you grow oh yeah um i think
i think when i started uni
and i started uni oh i don't know so
yeah i might have had maybe like a few
thousand subscribers at that time
i think and you decided like and and i
guess the decision at this time kind of
talking sort of 2011-ish wouldn't have
been like oh i see an opportunity here
to make money presumably the partner
program either started existing then or
like i knew that it existed then because
this was also around the time when it
was like charlie mcdonnell the first uk
youtuber to hit a million subscribers
and like he was clearly making a living
from it but like
it was still very rare yeah at that
point like you didn't do it with a plan
to
start making money um
so i don't know i i do remember like
first signing up for like adsense and
there's a youtube partner but it but it
taking forever to even hit the threshold
where you like earn enough to like get a
payout yeah
but yeah no it was it wasn't like a
money thing but but i did see like
nobody's doing this in the uk i could be
that person and like
did have an i did have an awareness at
that point that it would make me stand
out i guess
yeah yeah so i guess it's like you found
the sort of intersection of something
that you enjoy talking about something
that you saw get sort of a gap in the
market for and maybe a maybe maybe sort
of hypothetically in the future a sort
of potential that this could be
interesting further down the line but
you don't really know what it looks like
then and i i imagine you wouldn't have
imagined yourself writing books or doing
a podcast or no yeah
no making a living out of being being a
sex educator yeah it was very much like
in those early days i was just riding
the wave so i was just like oh this will
be fun we can like make these sex ed
videos and then um
it was kind of more the the reaction to
it being so positive and actually kind
of being like
i don't know drawing a lot more people
in and and
that kind of was like oh
okay i think i've
i've hit on something here yeah
we're gonna take a very quick break to
introduce our sponsor for this episode
and that is brilliant i've been using
brilliant for the last two plus years
they're a fantastic platform for
learning maths science and computer
science with engaging and interactive
online courses and the great thing about
brilliant is that they really teach
stuff from a very first principles based
approach it's almost like the way that
we were taught in places like oxford and
cambridge where you learn a concept and
then you apply the concept to an
interesting problem rather than just
being spoon-fed stuff like we initially
learned in school my favorite courses on
brilliant are the computer science ones
as some of you guys might know i was
torn between applying to medicine and
computer science i went for medicine in
the end but i always had an affinity to
computer science and taking the courses
on brilliant like their introduction to
algorithms and their introduction to
python really helped me get more of a
grasp of computer science than i've ever
had before it's also great for learning
how to code which is an incredibly
useful skill to have especially if you
want to start a business and i attribute
like 98 of my business success to the
fact that i learned how to code when i
was in secondary school so if you want
to check out the courses on math science
and computer science then head over to
brilliant.org forward slash deep dive
and the first 200 people to sign up with
that link will get 20 off the annual
premium subscription so thank you
brilliant for sponsoring this episode
why are you so okay with talking about
sex
it's pretty unusual yeah to be very okay
with well so
i had quite an open household like
growing up
so like liberal parents so that would
have helped for sure i have this like
one memory from when i was about 12
that i'm like is this is this why i'm
the way i am like but also it could mean
nothing who knows so i'm sure we'll talk
about this at some point as well but
i've got ulcerative colitis
um which is a form of inflammatory bowel
disease it's a
autoimmune disease um
and i had a pretty bad flare-up when i
was 12 years old and this was very kind
of like
early days at least from my
understanding in medicine of like oh
maybe
um mental health and stress and stuff
can be related to like gut issues that
people have yeah um and i remember my
doctor saying to me like do you open up
to your friends do you share secrets do
you
or do you kind of like do you know do
you talk to your friends about how
you're feeling and stuff because also
you're like you're 12 and you're like
on the brink puberty like going you know
in high school and stuff and i was like
no because at that age i just like
bottled everything up did not share
anything like any crush that i had i was
like
like this is mortifying no one must no
one can know
um
and my doctor was like maybe think about
like
sharing things and opening up and like
you know because that can help with like
stress and stuff and like maybe there's
a link between stress and like you
having a flare up and things
and like i think i just took those
doctor's orders very literally
but that was obviously like when i was
quite young and so it was like a bit of
a gradual thing
but i just remember like
then around like 13 14 years old and
like
um
having friends over after school and
um showing like the boys in my class how
tampons and pads worked by like uh
running them under like the water tap
and being like look how it expands
and that just being like something that
i was like
very like compelled to be like the boys
would be like uh periods are like what's
the tampon and i'd be like well
just becoming a complete hermione and
just being like let me show you so i've
like always been like
teaching my peers about these things as
i've been learning them that's so great
like i was just thinking like i think
the first time i saw a tampon was when i
was like 25 and working on obstetrics
and gynecology
wow
and i just did not it was like you know
we'd have because it was it was the um
kind of early pregnancy you never saw
like any of your mum's period products
around the house wow i mean i saw that
she would put those vet is it like this
like in in the
i don't know is it vita hair removal oh
oh maybe it's terrible
there was this purple
package of stuff that occasionally would
happen like the asda grocery thingy oh
okay yeah maybe they were done
i didn't really think anything of it but
then it was when you know we were
kind of dealing with ladies who would
have early pregnancy bleeding
and
you know i remember my first weekend one
of them was like oh sorry you know i've
run out of pads could you you know give
me some and i was like
that's a
very good question so i went to the
nurse uh julie uh this lady's asking for
more pants and she was like oh ellie
bless and she was like she showed me
where they all are and she was like
right here are the sizes this is the big
one you know this is the maternity one
this is a special one
this is honestly why yeah this is
honestly why i'm just like so passionate
about like not having
um
not like separating
like the genders when like doing sex ed
and just being like girls in one boy's
another because obviously also
non-binary and trans people exist but
then like
if you're just going to be talking about
periods to the girls like
the boys will like need to be aware of
this stuff
yeah you know like
at some point even if they're not going
to be an absent guinea doctor like
it's it's honestly baffling yeah it was
like the the the sorts of questions i
was asking like
i think after my first week i was like i
just sat down with the nurses i was like
okay i have a bunch of basic questions
what is a normal amount of bleeding when
you're having a period
okay like what is a bad amount of
bleeding i was like okay if someone is i
don't know early pregnancy like how how
how how much blood is too much yeah
because you just you just don't have any
kind of conception of it at all yeah and
i guess when you're bleeding even a
small amount of blood like on the sheets
looks like a blood bath yeah yeah and
they would come in and be like oh that's
nothing yeah because it might just yeah
it's just like the tiniest amount but
like on a sheet yeah it looks like oh my
god like this is
this is a nightmare and and the things
we'd ended up and end up saying to the
patients after after after a couple of
days on the water was like you know
blood clots the size of a fist
are concerning less than that yes pretty
normal don't worry about it too much um
the size of a fist would fix yeah
if it feels like a tap that's turned on
that just won't stop that's bad that's
not normal so yeah please call an
ambulance if that happens um that kind
of thing uh
it's just good tonight just didn't like
never know but
um okay so you're kind of
19 20 ish at this point yeah uni you're
like
the the other weird thing about this
is that
i imagine most people in a position of
like i'm interested in this thing um
would not then jump to let me teach
other people about it because they would
have a sense of but i'm not an expert
i'm not a gynecologist i don't know this
that and the other how why would anyone
listen to me how could i possibly be
qualified to do this i don't have a
degree all of that stuff honestly i feel
that more now than i did then oh okay um
and
i always forget the name of it you
probably will know what's that like it's
like
some sort of graph thing oh the
dunning-kruger effect yes
i think what happened to me was a
hundred percent the donning krueger
effect
so for anyone who doesn't know basically
at the beginning you're like
you're getting to know a new subject
matter and you're like
your confidence is super high but your
competence is actually really low and
then the more you gain
competence you actually lose all of that
confidence
um because you suddenly start to realize
how little you really do know
and then
fighting through that and actually
persevering through that is what then
makes you
an expert hopefully at the end i i think
i'm in the middle still somewhere very
much um
but yeah no 100 it was just like
complete balls to the wall
confidence
so what sort of videos were you making
back in the day like
so it was actually with um with a friend
of mine um because i was like oh that
it needs to be a guy in the video as
well so that
i don't know i just for me i was i think
maybe that was a little bit of me being
like i can't do this by myself i need
like another voice
he was by no means an expert as well he
was just like
my friend he had good chemistry on
camera like good at hosting videos and
stuff um and i wrote all of the videos
um yeah so we did like a series of five
or six videos together and then like
they just started doing really well and
we weren't living in the same city so we
could only film together like when i was
visiting london
and so
um it just kind of like naturally
happened that like i just carried on
making my own videos about it as well
and so yeah so what sort of topics was
it i don't know like i think we started
with contraception we did stuff about
puberty uh virginity body image
i don't know i honestly haven't gone
back and re-watched those they're
probably like
so bad anatomy we did just like
literally just going through like and
what was the response when when you
started doing those
um just really positive just like loads
of people being like oh my god thank you
like
um
like i didn't know that or this is so
interesting or like nobody ever talks
about this like you made me feel less
alone or you made me feel normal or
um
and then also obviously like lots of
follow-up questions as well and stuff
yeah yeah
so that
that would have been sort of like seven
eight years ago then so what what what
has what's happened to your kind of
career kind of since since then yeah so
yeah i was doing youtube just kind of
like as a hobby and then it kind of
become like became this part-time job
whilst i was at uni so i did so i
started
making youtube videos before i went to
uni so then spent that three years
making videos and doing my degree
although like was not consistent at all
with the videos because
degree stuff just would take over i
honestly have no idea how like you or
like other study tubers like did it
where you're like but i guess if you're
making your channel about your studies
it's a lot easier it makes it a bit
easier um i was not
and so
well no there was some crossovers
actually because i did history and i did
a lot of modules and my dissertation on
sexual history so i did kind of like try
and like bring in some of that stuff
that i was learning into
my videos as well
and then
graduated and moved to london
um at that stage it was like okay this
is a part-time job i'm like every month
or two i'm traveling to london for like
events whether they be work stuff or
social stuff with like all of these
connections and people that i'm meeting
and i was earning some money from
youtube but not like
a not a full-time thing at all but i was
like i'll go to london get a part-time
job and like
see what i can
make happen and yeah i worked part-time
for
just under a year actually i i think it
was like 10 or 11 months of
doing youtube still part-time
until i got to the point where i was
like
okay i can
i can do this full time now but as soon
as i finished uni it was like right one
video a week let's go nice
so what were you doing like what was
your main main main gig as it were yeah
so when i first moved to london i got
like one of those jobs with a catering
company where you just like pick up
shifts here and there like doing your
thing i think i've still got like the
bottle opener
from that also like some very short you
have to like buy your own uniform and
like black trousers and i ended up like
and i didn't know how to sew and i was
also like um
crashing on like family friends
um like spare rooms for a while before i
found my own place
and
um i was like i need to turn up these
trousers because they're like way too
long for me and i think someone on
twitter suggested a stapler so that's
what they did i stapled your trousers
with staples
stapled together
it was great um but i only did that for
a little while because then i got a job
with this youth charity who i'd
previously
made some videos for
um
in the past so i already had a
relationship with them i moved to london
and they were like hey we are looking
for like a
video assistant basically so they
already had like a multimedia producer
for
um a lot of the content that they
produced and then i came on board to
kind of work with him
and write and host youtube videos for
them and it was a youth charity and so a
lot of the videos that i wrote and
hosted for them were about sex or about
relationships but then also were about
like mental health work school
um all of
in that kind of realm of things and then
i worked for them for about 10 11 months
okay
yeah and so at the point where youtube
was able to give you a full-time income
what was it like making that decision to
be like hey i'm gonna do this internet
thing yeah it was hard i like talked to
a lot of people
um because i was working for that
charity two days a week
and i was doing all my other youtube
stuff and it was the thing that made me
realize oh maybe it's time was because i
needed those two days
in terms of like to get all of my
youtube work stuff done i was like
i'm i'm like full like i'm at capacity
now with everything because like a lot
of the youtube stuff just kept
picking up and kept getting busier and
everything and i was like
you know the charity job didn't exactly
pay very well in terms of a day rate
um
and i was like i need i need this time
back um to work on my own stuff
um yeah and just like thought about it
and talk to people about it for okay a
while and then and took the plunge i
think it was i think i like handed in my
notice and then
left
and then went to vidcon and then came
back and then it was like
let's go here we are
were you concerned at all about the
youtube thing not being a real job
and what what what is your career going
to look like 10 years down the line
making videos like all of those fears
that people have as they switch from
a quote proper job to a quote like not
proper job
i don't know because i never i don't
really ever feel like i had a proper job
yeah because
um even what i was doing for that
charity like i was a freelancer
i
and i was making youtube videos but just
for somebody else
um which if anything was proof very
early days for me that like
this is a skill that other people also
want like and will pay you for
but i think i have more of those fears
about like the longevity of it now than
i did then like at the beginning i was
just like
i'm riding this wave like this is going
well like
why let's not like freak out let's just
keep going like build on this momentum
just
like i'm i'm riding this wave and i'm
having a great time
um
but also it was just me then whereas now
it's like
i rent a studio space i have a team
like there's definitely a lot more of
like the business
element to it
now as well and maybe you can relate to
to this as well um
and then also like having a baby and
like and like you know um
at the beginning i was like in my early
20s had no
dependence um had savings so i was just
kind of like
your early 20s is when you move to
london and you take risks that's what
you're supposed to do right
um so it didn't
i didn't feel any fear there because i
was just like if this all goes tits up
like that's normal i'm 23. like
who cares
um
whereas now it's like oh i'm about to
turn 30 i'm about to have a baby i have
a mortgage um
i have a team i have a business that has
a lot of overhead costs
so actually
a lot more fears about the longevity now
than then for sure yeah so on the point
about your 20s being for experimentation
i think that's
that itself is kind of a novel thing
depending on
on i i i guess
for
medicine in particular your 20s are for
setting yourself up for success in
banking and consulting and law your 20s
are like hey let's hustle hustle hustle
so that's when i'm 30 i'll have made
partner at mckinsey or whatever people
do
and a friend of mine um who's also it
was also medic in my year who recently
quit medicine to pursue a job in tech
put out a tweet that went viral the
other day which is basically like you
know
when i left medicine at 26 i was really
scared because for the last 10 years i
had a very clear path and now it feels
like all this uncertainty but then i
realized actually my 20s are for
experimentation that tweet went viral
and people like was it i think the the
the idea that you can actually just like
screw around doing stuff in your 20s and
it's actually okay yeah yeah it's
actually fairly novel to a lot of people
yeah i think
we put a lot of pressure on on people to
make a decision about the next 10 years
of their life really early like and
you'll know this like from doing
medicine at uni so like at some point
you decide you want to become a doctor
okay you have to do medicine at
university okay in order to get into you
need to do medicine i need these a
levels in order to get into college to
do those a levels i need these gcses at
what age are you making decisions about
what gcses you're doing you're 14. yeah
you're 14 and you made like all of those
decisions for the next 10 years of your
life like we specialize real early in
the uk um in terms of like those
decisions that we're making about our
studies and our work and career and
stuff um i didn't have that because i
went the
humanities
root
um
but
yeah i do think that
there is a lot of pressure to like know
what you want to do and then also like
as a
culture we we kind of idealize and like
um
look up to
people who are really successful very
young we're like oh my god look at what
they've achieved and they're only 21.
like isn't that incredible but then you
find yourself actually comparing
yourself to a lot of these people who
you know have
had great success in whatever it is
they're doing super young
but
and we have this obsession with youth as
well i think
um
and i can't think of any like
examples off the top of my head that i
know are true but i feel like
i feel like something like margaret
atwood didn't start writing until she
was in her 40s or something like that
but maybe not her yeah maybe not that
specific example but like
i think
yeah there's
there's you've got more time than you
think yeah yeah there's a bunch of um
examples in tech in particular that they
get thrown around that yes there are
some you know
19 year olds find founding stripe or
facebook or whatever but actually the
guy who founded linkedin was in his 40s
jeff bezos was in his 30s when he
started amazon like there are people in
their 50s starting these companies as
well yeah and like it's it's not a race
and you know
this is one thing that i find a lot of
people doing in our youtuber academy
where
especially if it's older people
comparing themselves to the younger kids
and it's like if you're you know if
you're in your 40s and you've got a
family and a mortgage and a job there's
just no way you can give the amount of
time to youtube as like a 19 year old at
uni studying psychology who has one
lecture a week he's just like banging
out the content if you're over 60 and
you're retired maybe you've got loads of
time to dedicate to youtube like amazing
um
chelsea fagin who's the um ceo and
co-founder of the financial diet she
like um often talks about how i think on
her instagram or like on social media in
general she basically only follows
um influencers who are over 50.
because she's just like we're a youth
obsessed culture and
for her like she's in her early 30s and
she just wants to see
older women
thriving because we also as a culture
kind of like you know you're a woman and
gets to a certain age and suddenly you
become completely invisible to the world
and so for her she like is actively
seeking out these like positive examples
of older women just like thriving and
like doing their thing and i'm like i
love that that was brilliant that's very
cool yeah yeah i think like one of one
of my um kind of
fears about the future as it were is
like
what am i going to be doing when i'm 40.
back when i was big on the medicine
thing i was like the answer is easy i'm
going to keep on doing the same thing
whereas i honestly cannot see past uh
april right now in terms of my life yeah
right so there's a twilight book behind
you so i need to bring that up because
are you a fan of twilight of course
right so there's i don't actually know
if this happens in the book because i've
only i've not read them in a while but i
recently um
re-watched all of the films
and there's that scene when bella gets
pregnant and alice who's the one who has
all the visions and stuff just goes i
can no longer see her future yeah that's
how i feel it's like i used to plan like
i was like a five-year plan kind of guy
yeah you were i remember seeing one of
your videos about two years ago yeah it
was my five years
okay i love that [ __ ] yeah and then
got pregnant and then it's like beyond
the due date i'm like what is life it's
just like
they have no vision yeah i have no
vision like i'm very excited for it but
i'm like
can't plan can't who knows yeah so i
feel like alice cullen when bella gets
pranked he's like i cannot see
so like
pre pre-baby showing up how how were you
thinking about like the longevity of
your career and what you would be doing
x years down the line yeah
i feel like i was always grappling with
like these two
um
sides of myself one is the
can i swear please
[ __ ] this i'm out
peace out i'm going off i'm living a
quiet life
being a public figure is not for me
cannot handle this um and just kind of
being like i've done my time
as an internet person
um and then the other part of me that is
just like so excited by
sex and relationships and like um
educating people and like talking about
these topics and also so excited about
the internet and youtube and social
media and like building a business and
like um
expanding my team and doing exciting
projects and just being like oh what are
the possibilities so like these two
things i'm always like constantly
battling with and i feel sorry for my
friends because sometimes they just get
the like i can't handle it anymore like
that just i just want my partner to like
keep getting promoted and like earn
loads of money so i can become a
housewife
and then the next thing that they know
is they see me like advertising for a
new job role and they're like
hannah like
didn't you want to quit a week ago and
i'm like now i'm hiring somebody new
um
so yeah that's something that i'm always
like
yeah i don't know just like have this
like
inner tug of war going on i'm currently
in a good phase with it though because i
have just recently hired someone new um
and so i'm in that like
i don't know just like the possibilities
isn't this great and also like with the
baby coming um
it's very much kind of like i'm trying
to set my business up
in a way that actually allows me to step
away from it a bit more and because i'm
not going to be able to work
full-time um like if we're just being
realistic about it um
what is it like being a kind of public
figure internet celebrity type person
specifically in the realm of sex and
relationships
yeah it's
it's a weird one one of the things that
maybe i don't know like depends on the
day of what bothers me the most when you
are
somebody who like you know you're saying
i'm very open and i talk about a lot of
these kind of like taboo topics and
stuff and so a lot of the time
people like open up to you
in return which is an absolute like
privilege because like people are like
being vulnerable um but sometimes like
you just you don't have the emotional
capacity to take on other people's
um
like emotional dumps sometimes then
there's also the like
having to be really clear about
boundaries
in terms of like what is an okay
question to ask me
versus what is are like you've
overstepped the line like just because i
shared information about this one thing
doesn't entitle you to like make a
comment about this thing or ask me a
question about this other thing people
feel like they kind of
and i think this is also like a being a
woman on the internet thing as well but
like a woman who talks about sex on the
internet kind of then just gets
exacerbated a bit where just people are
like
feel very entitled to you and to your
body and to like make comments on it
um
what does that look like
i just can't really imagine like yeah i
guess in the world of productivity
youtube but
it's a very different kind of you get no
comments about your hair your bed you
talk often talk about your like gym
shark athlete yeah sometimes oh the
biceps are looking good or oh i prefer
weather without the beard or keep the
glasses on mate or yeah yeah and a lot
of it is just like
either from just kind of like older
creepy men or it has this tone of like
oh this is like unsolicited advice or
it's just like completely irrelevant but
i'm just gonna comment on your body and
i remember like because i was really
open about the fact that me and my
partner were trying to conceive um for a
while before we did get pregnant
and i remember saying i was like
i'm i'm gonna share stuff when i'm ready
um so it's not gonna like these videos
and these updates aren't going to come
out in real time um so in the meantime i
would like appreciate it if
you didn't speculate
yeah like no comments being like oh you
may are you pregnant like you look a bit
pregnant or like oh is that a is that a
bump or things like that like because
that can be really hard to
um read if you're trying to conceive and
you're not pregnant right
um
and also it's just weird like why do
people feel like they can say that to
random strangers on the internet it's
just weird
um
but most of my audience are like super
on it i think also like being someone
who talks about sex and relationships
and like consent obviously being such a
huge part of that
having consensual interactions with your
audience online where i say this is a
boundary of mine and them going yep got
it
noted nice um
so yeah i do i do feel like i'm very
lucky in that sense because
me and my audience are so used to having
conversations about consent that when it
comes up in terms of our relationship
they're very respectful and just like
get it but then you do get these people
who just come in from the side sometimes
and they're like
but then it's quite nice because then
you see like
clearly some like more regular members
of my audience like swooping in and
being like well actually excuse me
that's not very nice like don't say
um yeah so that's kind of like one area
of it and then another is just like the
constant anxiety and constant like
pressure of like
am i saying the right thing am i good
enough and this kind of like
and i mean good enough in terms of like
your intrinsic like morality as a person
um because when you're like talking
about a lot of these issues like they're
you know they're part of like social
justice and they tie into so many
different um
aspects of people's life whether that's
like gender sexuality
race class like um disability like all
of these things and i don't know
everything about everything
and so there is a lot of like
am i saying the right thing like and i
do think that that comes from a good
place
and like more people should maybe um
be a bit more on it with like the
language that they use and like um
understanding all of these different
perspectives
um
but then i think there's a line where it
actually is like
detrimental where you're just like
you're absolutely exhausted by it and
you're like you're trying to
you're trying to predict other people's
reactions to things before they've
happened and you're like losing sleep
over people's reactions to things before
they've happened and just like
sometimes a lot of it comes down to like
self-censorship as well because you're
just like it's not even worth me saying
that but
what's an example of i don't i don't
even know if i've got like examples off
the top of my head so like are we
talking like oh i said women in that
video rather than people with uteruses
or it's
yeah well that's something that like
i've i
have learned and
that comes quite naturally to me now
okay um
but
oh i don't know i think
i don't know it's honestly hard to like
even think of examples off the top of my
head but like i want to set a good
example and i think sometimes there's
that like
you know the classic like with great
power comes great responsibility
and
i think sometimes you get you hit a
point where you're just like
this responsibility is crushing me yeah
and actually like i can't handle it um
and yeah
this interesting one yeah so it sounds
it sounds like kind of one major kind of
strand of
concerns is
response from the audience but even if
for example you turned comments off or
just chose not to look at comments or
anything like that you still got this
sort of crushing weight of
responsibilities because the the area
that you're talking about
it's no it's non-trivial it's like a
core part of loads of people's lives and
i genuinely take it so seriously yeah
because i know um
like how important and how like
impactful these like subject matters are
on people's lives i i do like to
very much like one of the things i say
in a lot of my videos is how like we're
all about tonal shifts here so we can
get like really quite deep um and talk
about something that's really quite
heavy and serious and then like i i also
will make like jokes about things or
like talk about something that's quite
light-hearted but still about like sex
and relationships and stuff because
i think that's really important to kind
of like have that balance with like the
joy and also they're like this is [ __ ]
up and we need to like
change the world
um but i like to kind of i don't know
voice that out loud of just like i'm
like i'm acknowledging that i'm doing a
tonal shift here
rather than just doing it and it kind of
like
i don't know people just kind of being
like what just happened
uh okay so if you're talking about
something serious and heavy and then
you're segwaying into something a bit
more lighthearted
that segue can seem jarring yeah and so
i want to kind of be like i'm aware that
this is a tonal shift
i don't know i feel like so much of this
is like so
nuanced and it's like
you have to like
experience a lot of it to be like okay i
get it i get like a lot of the pressures
there and i think it's like a lot of
being a woman on the internet but then
also like if you're in the like
social justice space as well um there's
a lot of just like
worrying about
oh i have to make a comment on
everything which is something that i've
very much like been able to let go of
okay
um
like there was a time when i would i
would get messages from a lot of people
being like why aren't you talking about
this thing why aren't you talking about
this thing why are you saying there's
something about this thing that's just
happened and i'm like i'm not a
news outlet
yeah so it's it's navigating a lot of
these things but they're just kind of
like
it's
it's all like it drips in that's the
thing it's always like
small little things but constantly there
are a lot of very good causes out there
in the world
and each of those
and and there are a lot of people out
there in the world and there is not a
clear mapping as to you know all of the
people care about this one cause and for
the people that care about
their their particular
cause like one to three causes those are
like absolutely huge deals and there's
nothing more important than climate
change or than animal rights or than
israel versus palatine or then yemen war
or whatever
and so when something comes up that hits
that particular thing other people in
the world would accept that obviously
this is an issue but it's not one of the
core issues that i spend large amounts
of my time thinking about
and so when it like you know for me
i'm i'm not a political or human rights
commentator and so when people are like
your silence on the kashmir issue is
deafening
it's like
no one needs to hear ally of dolls i do
not know
i do not need to open about things that
i literally have no knowledge of yeah um
and you know that's not gonna do anyone
any good but yeah you can't say
something about
everything yeah and yeah i i just kind
of like
i've got the things that i
talk about and even within my subject
matter i also just like can't know
everything that's going on and then also
like my position like as a like a white
cis straight woman as well like
sometimes it's like not for me to
be the spokesperson on certain
topics or issues yeah um that's one of
the things that i love about like having
a podcast as well just means that i can
be like
hey
you talk about this thing like any
questions to someone who yeah let me um
share my platform so you can
talk about your experiences and stuff
yeah
changing gears a bit what do you like
i just have so many questions about the
sex relationships
um
but and i imagine for example sex
education in the uk i would hope is
better than it was ten years ago um
what are the
what are the kind of core issues that
you see with how young people are
educated or otherwise about sex and
relationships oh
so okay so that's a bit tricky because i
mostly focus on like adult sex education
but i can i can give it a shot um
yeah it probably is better it also is
like a
school to school thing right um but in
the last couple of years um
relationships and sex education has
become compulsory in
schools in
england and wales i believe so that's a
thing however that's mostly come into
effect
during this time of pandemic so it's
basically just like something else for
teachers and schools to tick off
their already massive list of things
that they have to
do um on top of then
like
dealing with
you know doing like online classes and
stuff so it's not like being uh the best
time for schools and to like be a
teacher at the moment and even even
without a pandemic um
it's all well and good having
like
relationships and sex education being
compulsory but then if you're not like
giving schools more funding
and also like training teachers in like
how to talk about um these things
because teachers are people too and
often they're like in their early 20s
and also will not have had good sex
education so like
you know you've got to train the people
who are going to be um talking to young
people all these things so that's that's
my whole spiel about
that thing and so i think what i don't
yeah it's tricky in terms of like
the
the
tough things that young people are
dealing with i'm not entirely sure of
like the current state of sex edins in
schools but if it's anything like mine
was it's still very much like a
uh
preventative kind of
approach
as in so it's like how to not get
pregnant how to not get stis how to
not get raped
like
all of those kinds of things rather than
like
how to
uh have a healthy relationship yeah how
to
how to um
you know
like how to uh
figure out
like how how to like find your own
pleasure um
and how to enjoy sex how to enjoy
relationships how to
um communicate about all of these uh
different things
and and then also the how to get
pregnant if you eventually want to get
pregnant because school led me to
believe that it would be
easy
not the case
not the case for me anyway yeah i
understand why they like kind of do that
like fear-mongering thing because like
especially when you're younger you're
like super fertile um so
um and you know it could just it only
takes one sperm but also like
full so you know it could also take
millions until you get that one you get
the perfect one yeah
um yeah it's as you were saying that it
kind of reminds me of the shift that
kind of happened in psychology as well
where oh yeah from like treating like
disease to kind of like positive
psychology it's like how to live a
happier life and how to how to take care
of your mental health rather than okay
now you've got depression let's figure
out what ssri works yeah yeah kind of
thing yeah it's i guess it's such a big
topic area
how do you even begin to go about like i
suppose if you're like talking talking
about sex and relationships stuff is
sort of like one one issue at a time
or like it's so hard to do one issue at
a time because they all just kind of
like yeah they all connect with each
other and so i mean for the sake of
youtube and like making you know like
packaging up a video in a way that is
like
youtube algorithm friendly like you kind
of you you do have to kind of
i don't know figure out what your angle
is going to be
um
but
if you're like
you know if for my case where i'm like
making so many videos and making so many
podcast episodes it will be like oh this
thing blah blah blah blah yeah we went
into more detail about that in that
podcast episode or like in that youtube
video like we went through that so i
don't like so you're just constantly
like referencing all of these other
things that you've made because you're
just building this massive library um
of information um but yeah well on the
like the school thing again though so i
i interviewed someone for the podcast
who works for brooke um who are
ambassador for they're like a they're a
young person's sexual health charity
and we talked about the new guidance
like as it was coming in
um and she was like oh yeah i read i
read through it all and i did like a you
know like you know command f or like
control f like to search for like
certain words the word pleasure was not
in there
at all
um and then and then one of the other
big issues is um things like lgbtq plus
inclusion so it's like it's in the
guidance that your curriculum has to be
lgbt
uh
inclusive but then it's also very open
it's just very vague and like open to
interpretation because like faith
schools can kind of do what they want
um
and then also it's like
does it have to be inclusive in terms of
like you do one class on lgbtq plus
people exist or as it should be done
where it's like integrated in every
single lesson that you do and with all
of the topics that you talk about it's
all
lgbt inclusive you know it's so yeah
yeah i guess it's it it's hard enough
for a teacher in their early 20s to talk
about yeah the basics and then when you
add in the
kind of
complicating factor as it were of lgbtq
plus on all of the things you then end
up with this kind of very nuanced almost
mess of stuff where yeah with someone
who's i don't know a history graduate
who's never really had sex education
before in their life it's like how do i
deal with deal with this
for like you know teenagers that are
automatically not an ideal target
audience and we all have our own baggage
so like teachers have their own
ideas and values and beliefs about sex
um they also probably they might even be
holding on to some misinformation that
they've learned like but and a lot of
that like comes from
um just like how the mainstream media
talks about sex as well like so much
um
that is where we get so much of our
education from when we're not actually
like
being taught about it in a like a
structured
uh environment and so like
and then also like loads of people just
feel awkward talking about sex
um and so like
then you
get people
who
don't feel comfortable talking about sex
don't know how to talk about sex and
then suddenly like a 14 year old is
asking them like miss what's a [ __ ]
and they're like oh yeah because a lot
of it is not just about what you're
teaching but like how you're teaching
like are you t are
are you visibly uncomfortable when
you're delivering this like sex
adolescent are you
yeah can the can the young people pick
up on the fact that like uh uh yeah are
you like
are you giving off vibes that that it's
this is not something that you're
supposed to be talking about are you
giving off even if you don't say sex is
shameful are you giving off these vibes
that you might think that um because
you're like
feeling awkward about talking about sex
to some teenagers um
so yeah it's
it's tricky because you've got to this
we're all
products of our own environment and so
like and one of the things that i know
from
like doing sex education and stuff is
that like
you as the educator also have to like
unlearn like all of your own [ __ ] yeah
how do you
think about
how religion comes into the mix when sex
education is involved it's just like
abroad
this one this one's really tricky for me
because so i'm i'm a jewish atheist
myself
um which basically i'm i'm culturally
jewish but i don't
i don't have faith and i don't believe
in god and
um yeah very much an atheist um
i i struggle
um
when it comes to like well these are my
religious beliefs so i'm gonna pull my
kid out of
this
class because it goes against my
religion or like um
oh is that i think parents do
yeah there was like a massive um
[Music]
thing in the news like last year or the
year before
oh yeah honestly i don't know what time
is anymore
yeah 2019 2012 yeah yeah it could have
it could have honestly been 2019 but i'm
like last year right um
there was a school in birmingham a
primary school and they had a
um they had a program called no
outsiders
and i hope i'm getting this right um
where like one of the teachers
um basically
it was just like this i think they read
lots of different books and it was all
about just like
um it wasn't just about like um
uh
sex and relationship stuff but it was
like about race and religion and like um
different like family structures and
things and so like you know no outsiders
it was about like understanding
different people in their backgrounds
and stuff and there were
huge protests like a lot of the parents
like pulled their kids out of this class
and then there were loads of protests
like outside of the school and lots of
demands for the
teacher to resign or be fired like yeah
it was
it was a big thing um and a lot of it
because there were like lgbt parents
like in these kids
like illustrated books or something or
like yeah i i really like i struggle
with it but i'm also coming from a very
privileged place where i don't have to
deal with that on a personal level
because like i don't have any close
family who are
who are like super religious and maybe
have like homophobic or transphobic
views because of that but i know that
that's a very real thing that a lot of
people deal with um and i just
a line that i just really want to draw
is just like
like if
if being like queer goes against your
religion like you
like you don't have any right to kind of
like
um
make your
kids feel like [ __ ] because of that
like it's can be so damaging to young
people to grow up believing that there
is something wrong about them that there
is something sinful about them um
that if they believe in god that god
doesn't love them because of who they're
attracted to
like
oh
it's it makes yeah it makes me really
angry and sad but also as someone who's
not religious and hasn't had to like
deal with that personally i maybe don't
quite have the sensitivity
to
be the person to like talk about that um
because i think i can sometimes just be
like
like
get quite angry about it but
when it comes to like people that you
love and family members it is a lot more
nuanced than that
whilst i just i'm i'm very adamant that
like
you know
don't
kick your kids out if they're queer like
lgbt like young like young lgbt
homelessness is such a massive issue
because these kids have been like kicked
out by their parents um because they're
queer because they're trans or whatever
um
and i'm just like that is horrific and
then if someone's like well it's my
religion i'm like not an excuse yeah
yeah it's tough it's tough
what's the consensus uh on on things
like homosexuality things like being
trans in in in terms of
nature versus nurture
like didn't have you interviewed some of
the podcasts who talked about this stuff
okay so this is this is an interesting
one because i recently watched this very
interesting ted talk because so
basically you hear they're like um born
this way
argument yep
i was born this way there's nothing to
do about it yeah yeah yeah and i think
that has become a very like
strong
and compelling argument for a lot of
people i'm totally going to butcher this
so i i i very much believe
that
probably more on the like the nature
side like yeah people just like
they have their gender they have their
sexual orientation
and some people are
gay some people are trans like
that's it right yes um
oh what did this ted talk say it was
really interesting because it it
definitely like shifted a lot of my
perspective on the bond this way um
argument because you also see a lot of
examples
of um sexual fluidity right and gender
fluidity and all of these things so the
born this way argument is like uh
well they were born this way so it's not
their fault so we shouldn't punish
people for something that's not their
fault
but then that can kind of be weaponized
against the queer community when you
have people who maybe like actually come
out later in life or their sexuality or
their gender genuinely changes
because we need to be able to like make
room for those experiences too
um and then that kind of like pierces a
slight hole in the bone this way thing
and then like
homophobes and transphobes
can
use that and be like well they weren't
born this way they're making a choice
and like
yeah it basically just sexuality and
gender and all these things are just
like so much more expansive and
nuanced than the mainstream like would
lead us to believe and i think that's
brilliant and i think by like embracing
just like
how vast it is and just being like
really curious about that and just being
like
oh you were a lesbian for 20 years and
now you're
something else like
cool rather than being like oh but does
that mean that then other lesbians are
lying about their sexuality do you know
what i mean like
um yeah there's a lot of moralizing
around all of this stuff
yeah um that's
and everyone has some kind of like
some kind of view
uh and
it's just so hard to
actually
kind of
talk about this or i think like
understand it um
because it just seems like the more you
uncover the more
layers of the onion there are to peel
yeah and i'm very excited by that
obviously because this is like the area
that i've like dedicated like
my life so far
too um but i understand that can be
quite scary for some people because
they're like
aren't they just like straight people
and gay people and then maybe a few
bisexuals like and then
and then that's kind of like it yeah and
then anything that they then suddenly
kind of like starts to break down that
world view or challenge it
in any way it's just like completely
overwhelming and like as human beings we
love our categories we love being able
to put people in like nice neat little
boxes because we're like this is how i
make sense of the world
um
but
i quite enjoy the like
the world doesn't make sense
um kind of just like falling into that
and just kind of
letting it wash over you a bit and i
think it so like especially with like
trans issues and i just want to be like
super clear that obviously like i'm a
cis person talking about this
um
but um i think for some people it can it
can be
fairly easy to be like okay i understand
that like binary trans people
exist like
um trans men and trans women right
people who have transitioned but then
like non-binary people suddenly like
just throw a spanner
in the works for their in their brain
it's just like i don't understand and
that's because gender is just such a
like
such an ingrained and like rigid thing
in our society so many
so many ways of us understanding the
world are of understanding
um
things about like men and women right
um
and i hear a lot of things from cis
people saying like
i just
don't get how somebody could not feel
like a man or a woman
or i just don't get how somebody could
feel like a man and a woman
and
do you know what as a cis person as
somebody who is like
i'm a woman i i identify with womanhood
like
that makes sense to me um like the the
gender of women i'm like yeah cool yeah
that works for me right
um i also i'm like
how could anyone identify as a man you
know what's that about like um but then
but more so with like non-binary like
even i'm like
i can't understand what that feels like
yeah but actually that doesn't matter
the fact that you don't get it
doesn't mean doesn't take away from the
fact that non-binary people exist they
absolutely deserve our respect they
deserve rights they deserve access to
health care um
same obviously with binary trans people
um
and actually like you not getting it me
maybe sometimes not getting it doesn't
matter
yeah i think it's a a lot of the same
stuff when when the
black lives matter was
trending
a lot a couple of years ago
um and it seemed like everyone on the
internet was reading reading all the
same books where they were talking about
how kind of
you might not appreciate that
racism exists if you have never
experienced it but the fact that you
haven't experienced it doesn't mean just
it doesn't exist and the fact that you
can't imagine what it's like for someone
to be
overtly or covertly mean to someone
because of their race that
well that that's kind of a area that's
kind of irrelevant we should listen to
the lived experiences of the people who
are actually going through it and yeah
quite understand yeah because
because with all of these different
issues like if you're not personally
impacted by them if you're constantly
like if you're constantly trying to have
that argument instead then you're just
going to you're you're just going to be
like
stuck in this like well justify your
existence to me justify your oppression
to me
rather than actually being like
right okay no i believe you
right how can i help
like let's move on like what what comes
next what like what do we need to do to
make the world a better and safer place
for you instead of worrying in this kind
of like
intellectualizing of like is it nature
or nurture or like does racism exist
spoiler yes it does and like
yeah i think we can kind of get stuck
there and like maybe there's a time and
a place for those kind of more like
theoretical
um discussions but when we're talking
about people's lived experiences
and like if we actually want to
make life better for them then
i think we we just need to kind of like
be like right cool got it yeah let's
move on let's crack on nice
you talk a lot about sex and
relationships we've talked about the
whole like
creatory stuff we talked a bit about the
sex stuff yeah what
i wonder so this is switching switching
to the relationships angle
um
broadly
what are the things that make for a good
romantic relationship and what do what
do you see in your audience and in
people that you speak to about the stuff
that people commonly get wrong about the
whole relationship stuff oh my goodness
i feel like there's there are just so
many things because there's like so many
like assumptions and and tropes and like
ideas we have about relationships from
like romantic movies and stuff
that um
we're like
when we then find ourselves in a like a
serious romantic relationship we're just
like
wait it's not like it's not like in the
movie it's like what's going on yeah um
so what are the key differences of movie
versus irl so so i think one thing one
myth that i've always enjoyed busting is
that love does not conquer all okay um
so i think
you know we have this like romantic
notion that love conquers all if two
people like
truly love each other
you know they
totally are in love like respect each
other like
their like interpersonal relationship is
just
magnificent right
that whatever hardships are thrown at
them throughout their life their love
will be able to
see them through and they will be able
to like stay a couple and stay in love
and stay together throughout it
i disagree
i disagree i think um there are a lot of
just like practical life factors that uh
however unromantic it sounds can
contribute to
a relationship working out or a
relationship ending
and that could be things like uh
distance could be things like work could
be things like
your belief systems and values um
could be things like
uh sickness
uh and health um it could be financial
people
often forget to talk about money in
relationships um and that can cause huge
rifts
love does not conquer your bank account
unfortunately
yeah that's one of that's one of the big
things for me is that like whilst it's
it's really nice to think about
love in that way and like it can help
sure if you two are really into each
other
like it can help because that gives you
like the motivation to be like is this
something that we can work through um
but ultimately like
love is not the same thing as
compatibility and i think compatibility
is something that we have to get like
really honest with ourselves about
in terms of like
are we actually a good match and i guess
that comes from actually just talking
about it from talking about it but also
just like from knowing yourself from
um lived experience from just like yeah
really getting to know yourself and the
other person and and
have having experiences
together instead of sometimes just
talking about hypothetically
having experiences together or what what
like going on holiday together and
things like that or that could be a huge
one like you might really love someone
and it turns out that you can't live
together
but there are
um relationships um living apart
together
where like two people are completely in
love and they manage to find like a
structure um and a system that works for
them where they don't actually live
together but they're in like a very
loving
long-term relationship
um that's maybe like one of the other
things is that like
we have this um idea of this
relationship stages right
um
oh i think there's a book or or
or maybe it's a blog post i don't know
but maybe it's a book that i haven't
read but i just like hear a lot of
people talking about which is like
called riding the relationship escalator
or something where it's just like you
start dating someone you get on the
relationship escalated together and then
you're just riding it like you're not
actually in control
does it escalate or elevator who knows
but um but but the idea is the same it's
just like
there are these like clear relationship
stages that our culture and media and
tradition and
um
and even like
our politics as well in terms of like
rights and benefits and stuff that you
get from hitting certain life stages
yeah so like sometimes
you you might be on that path
um because maybe you think that that's
what you want but actually like have you
thought about what it is
that actually you want and what kind of
lifestyle would suit you um
or are you just kind of like doing these
things because you're just like well
that's what you do when you're in a
relationship that's what you're supposed
to do in life like you date for this
many months and then you move in
together at this time and then you get
married and then you have a baby and
like
you know i'm saying all this as somebody
who has very much like kind of followed
that trajectory but
me and my partner along the way
like every single stage we're like
having these really deep conversations
about like
where is this desire for us to do this
together coming from
like is this something that we just feel
like we should be doing because that's
the next logical step
of our relationship and that's just what
people do
or is there something that we
as a
you know as a as individuals but also as
a unit like is this something that's
important to us and like along the way
just like every single thing just being
like
is this something we want to do and
actually drilling down to like why
and that's something that you say a lot
and i think a lot of your videos is just
being like ask yourself why ask yourself
why again ask yourself why again and
that like
doesn't just apply to like
work goal setting but like personal
relationship goal setting as well for
sure yeah like why do i actually want
this thing
yeah and and
there will be an element of like oh well
it will make my parents happy right and
you can choose to listen to that yeah
but you could also choose to ignore it
if it's going to make you miserable
right
yeah one of my one of my big whys for
the whole relationship thing is i often
i've heard a bunch of
studies referenced rather than kind of
read them in their in their original
state and basically say that your
happiness in life basically like
correlates quite highly with the
strength of your kind of primary
relationship um have you
come across this stuff like is that is
that like a thing
um yeah again i think it's something
that i've like seen referenced here and
there but yeah i think this is something
that again like similar to you i think
i've just like come across it being
referenced but
yes like your
um
primary relationship and your
satisfaction within that primary
relationship has a massive impact on
your overall life satisfaction that make
that makes perfect sense to me um i
don't know whether those things are
talking about like romantic
relationships because i i hear primary
relationship and i'm like well what if
your primary relationship in your life
is with a friend yeah or um with a
family member or or something but i
think that it would still kind of like
hold true that premise of like
do you
do you have like a person or do you have
like
your people
um
because that can absolutely impact your
life satisfaction and again there's
there's some other studies that again
i've seen like referenced and stuff
which um
is like people with kids their general
life their overall life satisfaction
goes down um which is so interesting to
me because it's like the same people
that like when interviewed it will be
like oh my kids are the best thing
that's ever happened to me and they
bring me so much joy but then when
they're like um
they're surveyed yeah if you're serving
a day-to-day happiness yeah then
actually their overall life satisfaction
is actually lower than people without
kids um so there is like i don't know
this cognitive dissonance for people
with kids where it's like you're going
to be less happy but also
they're the thing that brings you the
most joy in life yeah so it's like
it's an interesting one i remember like
reading something about that when dan
and i were like trying and i was like
you ready for our life satisfaction to
go down um other things to be aware of
especially if you're like a um
if you are a straight woman there's also
stuff and again like
i cannot reference the actual like
studies and stuff but i um
it's just things that i have referenced
and i think maybe there's some of it in
um the book of invisible women when a
man and a woman marry each other the
man's
life expectancy goes up and i think his
happiness goes up and a woman's life
expectancy goes down
and yeah and you're just like
interesting literally marrying men is
killing us
i'm like great it's a sacrifice i'm
willing to make but
with things like that though so that's
all like very hypothetical and like
isn't necessarily going to
you're not necessarily going to like
notice that in your actual interpersonal
relationships for me as somebody who
like finds learning about these things
interesting that's all it's always
something that i bring up with my
partner i'm just like did you know
just so you know like kind of thing um
but obviously if that's not something
that you would directly talk about in
your relationship um
it's still
i think especially if you are in like a
cis heterosexual relationship as well
just
for me it's really important being very
aware of
gender roles
and like i'm someone who considers
myself like quite aware of these things
and yet in my life
notice myself
and like me and my partner like slipping
into more like traditional gender roles
and having to be like hang on hang on
did we choose this or is this something
that we're just like falling into
because it's the examples that we've
seen it's because of like how we've been
raised it's um
it's because of just like
how we assume that we're supposed to act
because like
when you think about little kids right
in the way that they behave they're just
mimicking adult behavior right and i
feel like that we're doing that through
our entire lives like i'm someone who's
almost turning 30. who's pregnant and
about to have a kid
how do i act i'm just gonna mimic
what i've seen in movies i'm gonna mimic
other pregnant people that i've seen i'm
gonna mimic other people in their 30s
like that's what i'm doing like i don't
know what i'm doing i'm just pretending
and copying other people right for me
it's about like especially with the
gender stuff in our relationship it's
like
okay are we just copying
other couples are we just copying what
we've
seen are we are we just playing house do
you know what i mean like um
or
is this actually
what we want is this actually playing
into our strengths and weaknesses as
individuals and how we can best come
together
um to support one another you proposed
to then yes that's again
kind of unusual kind yeah yeah
what was the story there um
it was
it was a weird one because we'd actually
like
already talked about getting married and
basically like agreed to get married um
but i just like wanted to do a proposal
as well
um
because like it was it's a bit of a
weird one basically like we were living
together we knew at some point we wanted
to like um have kids yeah and that was
really important to both of us i cared
less about getting married but for him
he wanted to be married before having
kids like he was just a bit more
traditional in that sense
um
and then because of my
colitis and stuff i ended i had an
appointment with my
um gastro consultant
and
basically just kind of like
learned about the fact that because so i
had my colon removed
and i have a rectal stump this is like
what's this got to do with marriage and
kids hannah well
um and i was told
basically like i'm gonna have to have
like yearly uh flexible sigmoidoscopies
to take a look and make and take
biopsies and just like check for
inflammation but also check for like
pre-cancerous cells and stuff
and uh the doctor's just like you can't
have your rectal stump forever because
your chances of um rectal cancer like
increase like as the years go on um so i
will have to have surgery at some point
to have it removed and i'm like okay
fine um and then also if they go in and
the biopsies come back looking a bit
scary then they'll just like wipe it out
straight away
or rip out straight away even um but
then what they said was do you want kids
because
um you will need to complete your family
is this something that doctors are
taught to say because all of the doctors
the languages complete your family yes
yeah it's a very standard phrase wow
yeah i was like what
um
yeah so basically it's just like um
the kind of surgery that i would need to
have my rectal stump removed would
dramatically decrease my fertility so
then i was told
hey if you want to have kids like
get a move on
so yeah so then i rang down and i was
just like this is what the doctor said
so like
we doing this and it was like yep okay
we're doing this so then we were like
okay and my parents were going to be
traveling
uh the following year 2020 obviously
they ended up coming home a bit earlier
um but we
talked to them and i was like mom dad
when are you going to be back in the
country yeah and then we were like okay
great we'll get married then
and then i think after that conversation
i then proposed so yeah so it was like
okay we're getting married yeah
and then i was like i still did a
proposal because i was like
and then i wanted a ring as well but the
ring that i my engagement ring is
actually one that i've had since i was
18 that was like an heirloom from my
granny and so i said to dan i was like i
still expect a proposal back before we
actually get married and he got it in
there like within a few months of us
getting married i was like but i've
already got the ring like you don't have
to worry about a ring like this is the
ring i have it seems like the two of you
at least from from what i see in the
videos and kind of hearing hearing you
talk like this
are
are a bit like
rogue in the way that you do stuff
completely it's interesting that you say
that because in so many other ways we're
so conventional okay we're just like a
cis-straight couple
who started dating moved in together
yeah
got married and are now having a baby
like that's a good point
and we're monogamous right like so much
of like our relationship
but maybe like as a sex educator and
like the kinds of um
stories that i hear and like people in
my like sex positive network and stuff
have
vastly different kinds of relationship
structures and styles
i'm like
compared to that i'm like oh we're like
so
conventional but then like yeah when you
compare us maybe to like
you know mainstream or whatever like
whatever the like the dominant
kind of like narrative about
relationships then
yeah maybe we do things like slightly
differently but i'm like by no means is
it is this the most radical thing
um what's your what's your take on the
whole idea that um you know you've got
this honeymoon period which some people
say it lasts from anywhere from for a
few months to a couple of years and at
that point the passionate love
disappears and it gets replaced with
compassionate love which is more of a
slow burn that happens over time
i've seen like a sort of bro science
about this but like is that legit
yeah okay so yeah
and i think like it's not something to
be afraid of um
like
you're in um in like polyamorous circles
um they use this language called new
relationship energy
um like nre there's lots of
initialisms and just like
vocabulary for things in polyamory which
i love
um
yeah so
what what that is at the beginning is
like this new relationship energy and
the thing that i always try and remember
and to tell people as well is that like
that initial
energy that passion
that honeymoon period like it's not a
bad thing that it will end because
people think like oh that you know like
after that six months to two years or
whatever then like then your
relationship is stale and boring
and i'm like no like everything in life
has phases yeah and
and it's about just like
loving and embracing each phase for what
it is because if you're constantly
longing for
something that was in the past or you're
constantly longing for like the next
thing that's going to happen then you're
going to be really dissatisfied with
what you have
yeah um
and yeah for me it's just all about like
just completely accepting that like
there's going to be lots of things that
are out of your control as well um
the kind of like timelines for different
relationships are just going to be so
different other things can impact your
relationship like i
um when i got really ill and was in
hospital for a month that was after dan
and i had been dating for a year and so
obviously our relationship like
dramatically changed after that like as
it as it would like going through
something like that well it was just
like you know we'd been going out for a
year
and
we you know were in love
and
honeymoon period or like whatever at
that point and then suddenly like i got
sick
um me getting sick meant that our
parents were meeting but without
us like being there so our lives just
got like intertwined a lot more um i
think it just kind of like made things a
lot more serious because like
when you're in your mid-20s like sitting
by the hospital bed of your girlfriend
who is like really sick and you don't
know if she's going to get better like
that's not a normal experience for a
couple in their
early mid twenties um and then like once
i was recovering and like back home and
stuff it was like
well he's
like my partner but he's also kind of
like my carer like for this time as well
um yeah and i think it just does a lot
of like
oh you stuck around
you know so like
you know you're a good one
um
yeah so i don't know if like
who knows how our relationship would
have gone if that had never happened
like you just don't know and like
there's all sorts of stuff that can like
just be thrown your way a relationship
and you just kind of and just a lot a
lot of it is just like rolling with the
punches and just being like
how do you cope with this how do you
deal with this as a
as a couple
um and that can kind of like
show a lot of
people's character um i guess
and
yeah it all of these things are just
different phases
like i can't go back to a time where i
didn't have like a massive scar and a
stoma bag like that doesn't exist like
you know you can't you you can't
go back to a time when
you have like new relationship energy
there are ways though because like
you know if you're if you're into
certain things there are like
ways that you can try and like
manufacture it
um which can be quite fun because you
have that like
esther perel is a really great person to
listen to on like long-term
relationships and desire and stuff she's
amazing and she talks a lot about this
like how desire thrives in
um situations of risk taking and
uncertainty
and and all of that and
those things do not lend themselves well
to feeling like you're in a secure and
stable loving relationship so it's like
how do you
balance that novelty
with the like with the familiarity which
is also very healthy and can be good for
long-term relationships and so it's
about like
how do you how do you create situations
of novelty and i think the pandemic's
been hard for a lot of people like
dan and i just like every day is the
same it's just like it's really
difficult to create novel experiences
together when it's just the two of us
just like hanging out in the house the
entire time yeah
phases and just like accepting them just
accept them it's fine what are some high
roi things that sort of like
communication wise or anything that you
can do in in a couple
that would potentially
help mitigate against some of the issues
that people have kind of regarding
communication and things like that if
that question makes it make sense oh
yeah i think i know what you're getting
yeah so i think like understanding that
like you're not going to be perfect at
communication and like fumbling your way
through bad communication i think is
better than like not communicating at
all but there's like lots of little
things that you can do to make
kind of like saying the more difficult
things easier and and
i've learned the hard way that if you
don't bring these things up they will
just simmer and they will become
resentment and anger and then they are
just going to come out completely in an
uncontrolled way
and what you want is to be able to like
say these things in a very controlled
scenario so you can actually have like a
productive conversation about these
things but like
for instance if being in the same room
is really difficult when having that
conversation like
i don't i don't necessarily believe in
like
the hierarchy of like communication like
like face to face is best i'm like if
you if you're really struggling to say
that thing face to face then maybe write
it down or text them or like a phone
call or something like
as long as like that message is getting
across i think if you
are having no face-to-face
interaction in your relationship then
work on that because
there is a lot that you can
gather in from those uh interactions um
but like
things that i
love doing is like if you're going for a
walk together
you can always i always find like you
can have like quite deep conversations
when you're going for a walk because
you're not looking at each other you're
like you're like looking ahead anything
that kind of like gives you something
else to focus on as well sometimes uh if
you're like sitting together but like
back to back
and talking is really nice because you
have that contact point between you so
there's that closeness and that
physicality there
but you're just talking at a wall and
for some people that can be like a lot
easier to then like say some of the
harder
things
um
but you you have that comfort of like
still being able to like feel
their presence um there and then i think
like just one of my favorite things in
terms of communication relationships is
like
relationship audits and check-ins
which i think was maybe what you're
getting at and i i love these because i
i just think they're so important like
if it's something that you do like once
a year where you you um make it like a
fun thing you make it like a date night
right so it feels it doesn't feel
threatening it doesn't feel like
something that you have to be
worried about in the lead up to it's
actually something that you're like
looking forward to because it's like oh
we're gonna go to this fancy place for
dinner and then we're gonna do our
relationship audit or like we're gonna
go um to this gig and then like go to
our favorite pub and do our relationship
do you want to be like yeah like
it doesn't have to be a like right
laptops out let's sit at the
kitchen table and like like if you if
you make a like whatever works for you
in terms of like what puts you in a open
calm
relaxed
mood because you don't want to be doing
your relationship audit when you're like
on edge right you want to like
you want to be setting yourself up for
success in terms of like the context
that you create in the environment that
you're in um
yeah and like asking each other like so
how's the last year been
for you and like
what were your highlights in terms of
the relationship
what were your low lights is there
anything that you're interested in
working on next year for us together or
for me or for you as an individual
like
getting all of that out there and like
you know if you've had like a good
evening if you've had like a lovely time
together
then that
uh kind of interaction can like can be
really playful
and can be really like lovely
yeah yeah so that's something that me
and and my girlfriend do um on a sort of
every every three weeks or so like
there's a bit of a relationship review
we have like a notion template which is
convenient because you can look it on
the phone all right should we do a
relationship there's like 12 questions
that we just kind of go go through what
kind of questions do you ask oh
i'll give you a sample with my phone
let's go let's go
you can review these questions maybe
i'll steal some of them no mine and
dan's last relationship audit was like i
don't know maybe like a walk on new
year's day just being like
how's it been for you yep good any notes
that's a good one
[Laughter]
no we've not done like a proper serious
one with actual like listed up questions
i think
i i think because we're like
just naturally talking about our
relationship a lot because we're about
to become parents
it just like it just comes up yeah it
comes up quite a lot in terms of just
like
thinking about our dynamic and just
being like
what you know i don't yeah just
like especially because you know it's
the last few months of it just being us
too as well so you're like
how's it going and like how do you want
it to go and like yeah because i i guess
those sorts of conversations like often
don't happen by default
like it's so easy to get
kind of caught up in the day-to-day and
especially like in the early stages
stages of dating someone or in a
relationship where maybe you weren't
living together and you're seeing each
other once or twice a week and you're
doing something each time and this stuff
happening yeah yeah and then when's the
time to reflect on it
yeah hey when we did that last week like
i had a really good time and
this is how
this thing that you said made me feel
and i really liked that and
i was just wondering like if you also
had a good time you know it's like those
it's unusual to have those conversations
like in the moment and so making time
for them i think makes sense
um you know one thing that we do like
what went well in our relationship this
week how well supported by me did you
feel this week what's something i did
that made you feel loved appreciated or
respected this week what could i do
better or differently in the coming week
in the coming week and so we'd answer
the questions yeah yeah for each other
what are your main stresses at the
moment how can i help what went not so
well last week well
or last however however long that period
was um this is a good one is is there
anything at all i did this week that
made you feel not nice aka sad or bad or
annoyed in any tiny way how can i make
it better for us
and i find that that's a hard one i
always get really good data points on
this
okay cool
and i think i think with a question like
that you have to be careful with how you
answer it um
i
one of the things i always hear from
like
um like relationship therapists and
stuff is like using eye sentences so
like say if like we were doing that
order and you asked me that question
instead of being like well you did this
and you made me
and you
you're a bad person or like you're
insensitive dead ladder using an eye
sentence would be like
i felt like this
because of this thing that happened or
like
this is how you like making it actually
about
like
how um
what that experience was like for you
is how i've heard that it's better to
notice better to do because i think kind
of becoming with the like accusatory way
like you this you that the other person
can get quite defensive and actually
like sometimes we do need to like
own our feelings as well of like
oh i felt like this and
like i think that's partly due to
this thing that you did but then also it
might have something to do with like
this thing that happened to me in my
past um
and maybe like it it would be really
helpful for me if we talked about that
more do you know to be like yeah rather
than being like you don't understand me
yeah i've been i've been reading a book
recently called uh non-violent
communication ooh which is all about
this kind of like here is how we express
our feelings in this kind of way and
it's all about kind of making making it
about yourself yeah yeah i feel like x
when this happens yeah and it it becomes
not a it's not an accusation it's
literally just the way i'm feeling yeah
and i'm just letting you know and you
know i'd like us to talk about this if
that's all right with you kind of vibes
and then yeah there's no right or wrong
answer it's not like pointing the finger
at someone it's really kind of owning
the feeling
yeah because sometimes it can feel like
somebody's direct actions have like hurt
us in a certain way right
but other times
like i know that there's been times
where like dan has done something
perfectly reasonable
but i'm upset by it right yeah and so
it's about like sometimes it's about
still being honest about that yeah like
because sometimes we can be like oh my
my problems are insignificant like i'm
not going to bring it up
but actually like just being like
that like i felt like this like this is
how
that made me feel whilst also
acknowledging that like
maybe it wasn't entirely down to the
other person's behavior because there's
like there's a lot of things at play
when it comes to like how we react to
things and how we feel about things and
some of that will be like
the literal behavior that we are on the
receiving end of but other times it can
just be like all sorts of
baggage that we're also bringing to the
to the situation but being able to have
those conversations about like what you
do about that because even so even if
someone's behavior is like perfectly
reasonable like whatever you decide
reasonable in your relationship is they
might go okay like yes
this this thing that i was doing like i
know that
that was reasonable
but i see that it's upsetting you and so
i'm happy to like meet you where you're
at or maybe we meet somewhere in the
middle for the time being whilst we work
on this
and that doesn't necessarily have to be
a permanent thing like maybe that person
will eventually be able to like
go back to doing that thing whatever it
was before yeah yeah because i guess if
you if you if you care about how the
other person is feeling and like the
relationship itself yeah yeah that's
probably more important than oh well in
my view it's reasonable for me to do
this yeah because it's not about being
like right or wrong in that situation
like well it was perfectly reasonable my
actions so i take zero responsibility
for how you're feeling right now yeah
you know you know you're their teammate
you're their partner like just because
what
you know just because what you did was
reasonable or whatever
um
doesn't mean that you can just
completely take a step back from your
partner's
feelings and that's why i like that
question about like what's making you
feel stressed right now and how can i
help because that stress um wasn't
caused by you but you're still making it
part of your responsibility as
their partner yeah to help them with
that we have a bunch of questions from
social media
on instagram and twitter being like
we're going to chat to you what i didn't
see this oh i never see anything on
twitter these days yeah and a bunch of
people have asked questions okay so what
if we can we can bash you something yeah
patrick mcappell says is there such a
thing as the one and quote love at first
sight i believe that there is like lust
and infatuation at first sight and like
attraction at first sight for sure yeah
and vibes at first sight
oh yeah
love
no i think love oh this is maybe
controversial i think love is
a little bit of a choice
oh i think what do you mean i think i
make the choice to love dad every day
like i think falling in love
like that can be a bit more of a feeling
and like but then i think the staying in
love
yeah
is
isn't like an active choice nice which i
think is almost more romantic because
like i
i i'm like i i'm choosing you like and
that is an active thing that i'm doing
rather than just like oh well i love you
i can't help my feelings yeah it's like
some people say that love isn't a
feeling love is an action yeah or
falling in love is easy being in love is
harder
and then the the one no i don't believe
in the one i believe in many ones nice
across a lifetime here's a good one
underscore davis matthew is the concept
of a virginity useful to society no
it's completely
sexist and heteronormative and
doesn't
doesn't reflect a lot of people's
experiences um it was probably useful to
society when
i mean we still do but basically measure
a woman's worth off her virgin status or
not like whether or not she's had a
penis inside of her
um i mean that's what that's what it's
getting at because we think of it like
oh it's about whether or not you've had
sex but it's like no it's about whether
or not you've had
penis in vagina sex that's like what it
is digging down to which means that it
excludes all sorts of different kinds of
sex all sorts of different kinds of
people we have value judgments on
whether or not someone is a virgin or
not and that also will vary depending on
what their gender and their age is so
like you have somebody who is like an
older man you would judge them for their
virgin status but then you have a
younger woman and you would judge them
for their lack of virgin status right so
it like yeah
it plays out in all of these different
ways and i just think it is gross and
useless and we need to move on from it
okay um and instead talk about like
your first sexual experience
because people define sex and can define
sex in all sorts of different ways yeah
and some people will go through life
will never having penis and vagina sex
on a similar vein what's your take on
the usefulness of a number of sexual
partners
in any kind of yeah
i also think that that's another another
one that just like you shouldn't care
um
i think it's more about like
the attitudes that people have maybe
like i think it's a useful thing to have
conversations with like
potential like romantic and sexual
partners about like
their attitudes towards casual sex and
their attitudes towards like
why they've slept with that many people
or why they've not slept with that many
people
rather than it being about like
the number itself having holding any
information like
what does that as you would say data
point tell you like what like i think
actually being able to drill down to
with somebody about like
how were those experiences like did you
have a good time like
wha what was your motivation um for
like not having sex outside a
relationship what was your motivation
for like having lots of sex outside like
like casual sex and stuff i think that
will tell you a lot more about a person
than like the hard number itself um okay
yeah ali's thinking
[Music]
okay so i've uh for the record i'm with
you on this one um but i've spoken to a
few a few of my guy friends
and
tried to
argue that point of view of like number
of sexual partners shouldn't matter come
on guys you know it's a 21st century
let's move on et cetera et cetera
to which our response i've often heard
is
look there is a difference between
someone who's had three sexual partners
and someone who's had 300 sexual
partners what difference do they see
what's the difference that they're
thinking about is it like a difference
in like
a person's attitudes towards sex i
suspect that's probably what they're
getting at well so that's maybe what
they should be focusing on is like
also what standards do they hold
themselves to like are they also the
kind of person who would maybe only be
having three sexual
partners total right
because there can be a lot of like
judgment and double standards yeah there
as well so like for somebody who slept
with three people versus someone who
slept with 300 to these friends like
what information is that telling you
about them like what kind of girl is
that versus what kind of girl is that
and
what is it about one over the other that
you prefer rather than like so ignore
the number like actually drill down of
like what assumptions are you making
about that person's character what
assumptions are you making about that
kind of person's
um values or lifestyle
or sti status like we could be get and
so actually like
there's probably a lot of assumptions
that they're holding about these two
like fictional characters in their head
um
and and then also asking themselves do
you hold yourself to the same standards
like and how would you feel if somebody
else judged you a certain way based on
the
number of people that you'd slept with
yeah yeah and then just being like you
know you know it's absolutely fine i
think if for you
sex is something that you only want to
share with
uh you know a certain a certain kind of
person so maybe your your number is
lower and maybe the people that you want
to have sex with have have similar
values to you
it just so happens then
that your
both of your numbers are low
but it's actually the values that you're
holding in the beliefs that you're
holding that are the things that make
you compatible rather than like the fact
that you've both only slept with three
people
you could also have somebody who like
has lived a whole life yeah had a lot of
casual sex and then like come out of
that and been like actually like i've
now discovered that this is what i want
and actually i want the next time that i
sleep with someone for it to be like
somebody that i'm in a loving
relationship with so maybe they would
actually still be compatible with that
person but their number's way higher
yeah that's really good yeah i think
that's that that thing of like the the
the number is that it's not about the
number it's about the values that you
think that you're kind of assuming that
that number kind of correlates yeah and
we should talk about the values so the
next time one of your friends goes like
oh well i wouldn't i wouldn't want to
date someone who slept with 300 people
just be like tell me about that person
yeah this person this imaginary person
in your mind who slept with 300 people
tell me about them and what is it what
are the things about them that it that
you think makes them undateable for you
um on the double standards note yeah
another thing i've heard i i won't say
from friends because uh more like from
random bros on the internet
is
well men are evolutionarily psycho but
biologically designed to sleep with lots
of people women are not
um phrases like well you know
a key that opens lots of locks is a good
key and a lock that's open yeah all of
that kind of stuff oh my god how do we
deal with that first of all humans are
not locks and keys so can we just like
chuck that one in the bin also again
that metaphor
uh highly focuses on penis and vagina
sex which is not the only kind of sex
and also shouldn't shouldn't be the top
of the hierarchy of sex acts as well but
it very much is in our society in terms
of like what we think of as real sex
right what counts as sex
um so let's just like chuck all of that
in the bin please like no thank you
um but this like evolutionary biology
thing of like men spread your seed and
like women want to like nest and just
have one partner i would recommend the
book sex at dawn
uh it goes into a lot of this stuff and
challenges a lot of those ideas there's
another theory that um
is about how um it was actually like
women that slept around a lot in the
communities because it was um
better for the offspring if there was
ambiguity about who the paternal
person was the the father was of the
child because when you're living in
tight-knit communities
if all of the men
in your community are invested in the
well-being of that child that child is
going to
do fantastically if only one man is
and this other man is like well i'm
invested in my child i don't care about
that guy's kid
or if they're fighting over like
the patern like um
paternity
because like like you know who the mum
is like that's who that baby like came
out of um
but you know like we only know now these
days from like tests to like know like
100
100
sure
um so yeah that's that's another theory
and then there's also like something
that um we've seen recently like
fighting sperm so if you put like sperm
from two different
people's bodies in like
a petri dish i guess i'm not a scientist
together you see them fighting
so
if uh if a woman's like sleeping around
in her community the idea is that like
the best sperm will win yeah and so like
you'll have the best like
fittest strongest
um children there's i'll check the book
yeah there's there's all sorts of stuff
going on there that is not as simple as
um as
the kind of like traditional
um ideas that were given but
what i say is like even
even if they're true right
even if way back when it was a case for
practical reasons for resource
reasons or whatever
that that gender dynamic is true why
does that mean it has to be true now
because we don't have the same
we don't have the same resource
limitations as we did then we've got
modern medicine we've got
feminism yeah
like
we we have all of these new ideas about
people and about and we have all of this
um new
technology and
and
i think so much of like the idea is
about us like being slaves to our
biology but actually so much of modern
life
is about us like
transcending that overcoming our biology
right like
you know if i was chained to my biology
i would have to probably stop working
for an entire year because i would have
to like exclusively breastfeed
and i like probably wouldn't have the
time to work however like pumping and
bottles exist which means
actually dan can do some of the feeding
so already like technology means that we
don't have to
stick to those same roles that would
have been prescribed yeah yeah there's a
book i read recently uh the evolution of
desire which kind of talks about this
it's all of the stuff around like how
desire has evolved over time but his
main kind of conclusion if any is like
even though all of this stuff may be
true
we can still choose to not act in those
ways right yeah yeah that's kind of how
i feel about it as well i think i think
this is one of the issues that people
have with religion as well where maybe
rules and regulations that were set
forth 1500 to 2500 years ago may have
may well have worked for the time that
they're in yeah but
you know there is an element of
you know how many how many of the rules
are someone
someone quote made up two thousand
two thousand years ago do we really want
to continue following today yeah are we
making that active choice to do so
on
another thing that you said you said um
someone
you know a hypothetical person could
have had lots of casual sex and then
they
they're
they realize that they don't want to do
that anymore and they want to find find
someone else
there is a common trope amongst some
segments of the internet uh mainly sort
of the the men's rights activists and
all that kind of vibe
why are you gonna bring them into it oh
okay yeah i don't think you're a hero
taking this because it's terrified of
them honestly yeah yeah like they murder
lots of women well they in cells
especially but anyway that's a whole
other not quite yeah so so like one
one thing they would say is
it's really unfair that there are women
who
have their quote party years when
they're young and attractive and so on
and sleep around with those guys and
then when they hit a certain age they
realize oh actually i now need to settle
down with someone and therefore i need
to find someone who will be a good dad
rather than you know the
chad in inverted commerce is kind of the
the memes here who i used to sleep with
back in my youth
and um
a lot of these internet bros would have
the idea that this is fundamentally
unfair i don't know have you seen my
husband's bone structure he's a chat oh
he's a child
no what was the question
so so i guess the question is like
these these bros would put a kind of
value judgment on women who do that sort
of thing sort of thing saying that well
you know this is a case of wanting to
have your cake and eat it too
you kind of yeah all of all of that kind
of stuff yeah i honest honestly i don't
even know what to say to that because
i'm just like it's obviously [ __ ]
because like
men do it too
i'm just like yeah peop that's that's
just a human experience for some people
not everyone does that but some people
like it was like we were saying before
about like you know your twenties just
like mess around a bit if you want but
like some people meet like
the person that they spend the rest of
their life with when they're like 18 or
whatever and like that's fine too some
people like
spend their entirety of their 20s in one
relationship and then it ends and then
they find themselves in the dating scene
again in their 30s some people will have
like two or three major serious
relationships in their lifetime um
some people never will some people are
polyamorous like
i just
the people are different
let's get over it
um there's no conspiracy theory against
you when women sleep around and then
settle down with somebody like no
i am mara says what are the best the
best books to read to learn about more
to learn more about sex and
relationships
oh i have yeah i have some
recommendations i think come as you are
by emily nagoski
is a brilliant one that is one that i
just like recommend a lot and
um
has definitely like helped a lot of
people
um i don't i don't want to like
recommend too many because honestly like
um it can be quite overwhelming
um but that one is definitely a good one
to start with if if you've read emily
nagoski i would then like recommend
reading tomorrow sex will be good again
by katherine angel
that is brilliant
um mind the gap by dr karen gurney
um what are these books about so
so honestly like so so mind the gap and
come as you are are quite similar
they're very focused on like more so
like sexuality when it comes to people
with vulvas um but it's but it's just a
lot of like
how your body works and then also like
mind the gap especially dispelling a lot
of myths around like how um sexual
satisfaction and relationship
satisfaction is all about the frequency
of sex that you have um and actually
like it being about quality and not
quantity um and things like that and
then yeah there's a come as you are is
very like sex science
um kind of like distilling that for kind
of like public
mainstream consumption if you want to
like be like oh that's why my body does
that thing oh my god this is so like
normalizing and like because you know
there's so many
people especially folks revolvers who
are just like
what's
like am i broken right because we just
like have
all of these like really warped ideas of
like how our bodies are supposed to
react like sexual stimuli so there's a
lot of stuff in there just about like
desire and arousal and all of these
kinds of things and then like um
yeah mind to the gap has a lot more
stuff about kind of like
cultivating those kinds of like sexual
relationships in like more long-term
relationships and
there's a thing that i learned from that
book about sexual currency which i
really loved
um which is basically like so like
forgetting that like frequency of sex
is unimportant right it's about like the
quality and sexual currency actually
being this thing that is very crucial
for a romantic relationship which is
like the times when you're not having
sex
but you're still like relating to each
other as sexual beings so it could be
like flirting or making sexual jokes
with one another like a passionate kiss
a little grope of the bum in the kitchen
but it's like all of these little things
where you're constantly relating to each
other in a sexual way
you are acknowledging that the other
person is a sexual being but you're
doing these things
in a context where like it's not going
to lead to sex and there's no pressure
for it to lead to sex because sometimes
that can like shut people down as well
because they're like oh now they want
sex and so now my body is like shutting
down and i feel like pressure or
whatever um so i really love like the
sexual currency thing that i learned
from that book and then like
with catherine angel's book tomorrow's
sex will be good again that's a bit more
of a like
sociological and political exploration
of like
all of these
new conversations that are coming out
about consent and desire and arousal if
you want to kind of like
dig real oh it's interesting to that
yeah great i'll get on audible uh
links to all of those in the show notes
and in the video description yeah um we
end with a little quick fire around
which we do with everyone oh okay so
number one what advice would you give to
your younger self oh honestly i hate
this question because i feel like i
never have something good to say i
probably should always like know what
this is um
but i mean just crack on just keep just
keep doing what you're doing i honestly
just like it you know you'll be fine
who's had the biggest influence on your
career oh god i honestly don't know i
think it's like different phases
maybe but maybe like the vlog brothers
because like they were like some of the
earliest people that i was watching on
youtube and like the reason
why i started making youtube videos and
i still watch them to this day and i
just like think that they're such great
role models
and
um i really look up to them as like
older people on the internet they're not
old they're like in their 40s but like
you know they've been on this platform
for like 15 years whatever and i'm like
okay that's what
aging gracefully online looks like you
know
what's one tip for someone looking for
success really defining what success
means to you
um and then also just being able to like
focus on
the joy
in
your current life
as well nice
yeah uh what does the first and last
hour of your day look like these days oh
in my first hour
these days i always make sure i get my
word all in you're playing word off i've
dealt with it once twice yeah yeah so
that's a that's a that's the thing for
me in the mornings now and then the last
hour um maybe just like reading in bed
yeah cool falling asleep um what
material item under a hundred pounds or
so uh has has added disproportionate
value to your life toaster no
i like toast um oh god i can't think
under a hundred pounds
pop socket what a pop socket on the back
of my phone what's a pop socket oh my
phone's over there oh is it one of those
like yeah like it sticks out okay as
someone with small hands i feel so much
more secure
holding my phone
because i can like actually
um
text with it and taking a selfie i'm not
worrying about dropping my phone yeah
love it nice they cost like a tenner or
something sick uh what book would you
recommend to anyone anyone i don't
believe that there is a book that is for
everyone
but
the first thing that literally came to
my mind is that if you're into sci-fi i
would recommend uh becky chambers
wayfarers series the first book is
called the long way to a small angry
planet and if you like sci-fi bunch of
misfits on a spaceship a long journey
like found family lots of interesting
species and like dynamics between all
the crew
cool good fun very nice um if you got
cancelled and lost everything how would
you start again literally like my worst
nightmare
and
i
i i think i would honestly just be like
it's pizza yeah
i think i think if if that happened and
i really hope it doesn't but obviously
it's something that i think is a genuine
fear for me and a lot of my peers as
well um
i honestly don't know how i'd handle it
i've seen some people like really
like mentally struggle i would hope that
i would get a therapist
to
deal with that and then also
i don't know obviously it depends on the
context
that it happens in and whether or not i
choose to be like i'm going to continue
doing this work that i do because i
think that it's really important
or if i just kind of go thank you i'm
done
i have no idea yeah
um what quote or mantra do you live by
if any there's a song lyric from an avid
brothers song
that i love
um that is literally decide what to be
and go be it which i mean when i was
like
17 i found really inspiring now as
somebody who like understands a bit more
about like
structural inequalities i'm like you you
can't just decide what to be and then go
be it because like
um
different things have a way of making
that not possible but um
so i'm just like yes this mantra but
actually
and finally journey or destination
oh journey for sure nice love it hello
thank you so much for coming on the
podcast
people learn more about you
i'm uh hannah witton in most places
online
um my podcast is called doing it oh i
featured in that podcast you didn't link
to that episode
that was quite a while ago wasn't it
yeah like about a year ago i think um
yeah
yeah i asked all the noob questions of
that i i loved that chat i thought it
was really fun to make dating more
productive or something like that what i
think was the title
yeah i can't remember but yeah we talked
about like gamifying dating yes yeah
we'll stick a link in the video
description and in the show notes yeah
thanks for coming on thanksgiving and
good luck with the pregnancy
we'll see you around all right so that's
it for this week's episode of deep dive
thank you so much for watching or
listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye